happy birthday you're not special you
can't no they're not
special
hey everybody welcome to the worst
birthday podcast I'm Michael Kosta thank
you for listening we have saw a shitload
of new listeners thanks to itunes for
putting this podcast on the new and
noteworthy link category uh thank you
for that yeah I was like checking the
downloads and all of a sudden I was like
holy [ __ ] there's a lot more downloads
and then I went to iTunes just because I
do that sometimes and it's like here we
are number two or something on the new
and noteworthy so thank you very much
itunes thank you maybe it's because I
moved over to all things comedy maybe
it's because i have a new logo maybe
it's because the podcast is [ __ ]
awesome and everybody can relate to
having a worse birthday so i want to
thank you very much for that Thank You
new listeners I make these intros very
short because no one really cares too
much about the intro after the podcast I
also offer about five minutes of my
opinions so feel free listen to that you
can check out the podcast worst birthday
com please if you're going to tweet to
us please please please use the hashtag
worst bday pod you can email me any
suggestions or suggestions on guests
that you would like Michael at michael
kosta calm my twitter is at michael
kosta my instagram is at michael kosta
my webpage is michael kosta calm
upcoming dates Stanford and Sons in
Kansas City dr. grins and Michigan a lot
of good stuff which you can all find on
my website michael kosta calm you can
listen to me rabble the Wimbledon finals
men's and women's where you can watch
the match and hear my commentary on the
tennis and by the way we don't talk
about tennis half the time I just talk
[ __ ] thank you for listening Rick ingram
is a fantastic stand-up comedian he is
the guest on this week's worst birthday
podcast this is a great great great
worst birthday just listen I mean
it's it's a testament to our health care
system to stand up comedy 2 The Comedy
Store 2 diabetes two doctors this this
is an interesting [ __ ] story it's sad
it's exciting it's funny most of all I
love Rick Ingram as a comedian as a
person I can't say I love them because
that's that's tough to really get to
that level with somebody but he's a
tremendous comic and I am very happy
that he is healthy and and better so
please listen worst bday pod this is
michael kosta thank you for listening to
the worst birthday podcast now on the
all things comedy network and itunes new
and new and noteworthy say that five
times fast suck my dick everybody thanks
for listening to the worst birthday
podcast Walter speak speak speak that's
my dog okay love you guys bye
good to go yeah Ingram ladies and
gentlemen yes yeah so what is it what's
above the belly room at the comedy store
I've never even if you came up there if
you keep going up the creepy steps and I
mean it's as creepy as they get very
creepy uh it's it's one of the alleged
haunted places of the how many store
correct some guy who was a phone guy got
pushed down the stairs by a ghost he
claims probably just was on drugs and
fell down stairs but what year was that
happening uh I want to say that was late
80s Early 90s and how long have you been
there I've been there since 2002 but I
feel like Rick you I've always been you
feel like you I feel like you have been
there a lot yeah long time yeah I'm uh
it's pretty much the only the only spot
that gives me ample stage time so I'm
always there did you have you tried a
lot of other places yeah I mean I you
know I send in my avails to the factory
and the improv and the improv gave me a
first official spot in like three years
a couple weeks ago and they called me I
was like this isn't a good sis is we and
and I was right there was it was the
late show on a friday yet and there was
four people we started 45 minutes late
yeah I had a music duo comedy team
hosting [ __ ] and it was a nightmare I
mean you're one of these guys I'm sure
you're tired of hearing it but is so so
so funny yet I don't see you a lot of
other places and a month it must be
frustrating to you it is yeah i mean i'm
at that point now or I'm just I'm kind
of just fed up well yeah for years I was
like I'll just you know I'll get in yeah
yeah you know I've been past at these
places but you know I don't have any
credits and sure that seems to hold me
back from a lot of places and well and I
think for some comics that are listening
they think like okay once you get past
the Laugh Factory it's good to go after
that right getting past is very very
very hard yeah then you still gotta get
booked yeah yeah like I remember Jamie
past me probably eight or nine years ago
yeah did is when there was a laugh
factory in New York yeah and I did shows
there with dice okay you know I told me
if you come back to LA we give you stage
time yeah
I started sending in my avails and I got
spots there once a month yeah probably
for two years and then I never saw Jamie
at all in that time of course and and
then they have been it's been pretty
rare well it's easy to look at that
negatively it's also easy and hopefully
we can look at positively and saying
thank God for the comedy store yeah
absolutely this is thankful this place
is corrupt yep bitter dark depressive
and awesome everything I am and more
yeah it's uh it's great it's always been
good to me i worked there years ago yeah
but it's nice it's a renaissance of
times to there now it's crazy isn't it
so much better than it was I mean when I
got there it was dark days I mean so you
were there 2002 I was passed there 2013
maybe 12 okay and it was like there was
maybe a feeling of like something's
about to add her it's getting better
yeah I remember talking to you and like
Bobby Lee and re and they were like dude
you don't know the [ __ ] that's gone down
I mean people were having sex in the
green rooms all the time it mean it was
there was so little going on there that
there was people that would just have
sex in the main room unlike a thursday
night at like 10 yeah right there's
almost go on another go in there it was
the whole building was dark I mean for
the first seven or eight years I was
there yeah it was probably less than a
hundred people every night that's crazy
to me a decade close to a decade and now
now it's Sunday night it's sold out yeah
Louie popped in yesterday sold out main
room yeah it's crazy for those you that
don't know the comedy store this is a
place that on the Hollywood haunted
tours bus stops in front of it yeah
you'll be standing out there drinking
I'm drinking or not and uh I mean that
respectfully and the [ __ ] ghost bus
stops in yeah what are they talking
about do you know uh before is the
comedy store is a place called Siros
right which was like a gangster
nightclub yeah back in the day I had
you know there's like Frank Sinatra was
arrested for punching a guy in the face
there oh sweet and uh Dean Martin used
to perform there a lot and it just had a
lot of mafia ties yo there's rumors and
if you go to the comedy store you'll see
there's just endless rooms I don't know
purpose well that's what we were talking
before we started recording it's like
you're like oh there's a podcast room
upstairs and I'm like what yeah what
yeah it's it's it's crazy yeah and
apparently the mob you stood as they'd
off people there from time to time
because there's tunnels in the basement
yeah I've been to the back before they
locked up certain very not safe areas I
went down at the basement there's like
tunnels like one of them goes across
sunset yeah one of them I mean these
tunnels ladies and gentlemen you could
like open the door and go in the tunnel
it's not like they cemented them shut
least that I know of yeah i mean i don't
know what what their status is correct
we have the title status i know they
they prevent you from going in there now
but it uh yeah i mean they had all sorts
of things there was i guess fear of
raids and stuff so [ __ ] yeah I had him
open till whoever was not supposed to be
anywhere right could escape but I always
pictured it as just like some of the
mistress shows up right or someone's
wife shows up never get this runner
outrun the wipeout whatever take it
through the tunnel um what's the name of
the comedy store podcast it's just
called the compound or podcast and you
host it but you're having an issue with
people canceling and all this [ __ ] yeah
you get a lot of people will say they'll
do it and then whenever it is you
arrange to do it we're real flexible
with that too it's just like the
comedies here we can do there anywhere
we can do whatever you want so if you'll
follow do before after and people say
okay and then listen I gotta go yeah a
lot of people cancel like 10 minutes
before cuz sucks some quasi attractive
girl is giving him at the slightest bit
of attention did you live in New York at
one point no you never did okay because
you mentioned New York but the comedies
that I used to play this place called
Dangerfield's okay yeah but it reminds
me of the comedy store in its look but
the comedy store is like relevant and
has funny comedians yeah Dangerfield
sadly is not a lovely Dangerfield's but
you're not ah but it just reminds me of
that kind of feel
but um that the laugh factory when it
was in New York was very comedy story it
was asked and I was like wow this is
kind of cool but is like in an old one
of the old porn sections that shut down
yeah that was Zen a like Midtown er yeah
yeah exactly was like a whole I guess
all these SI joints yeah Giuliani I
guess closed mall down or whatever but
there's like three or four different
comedy rooms there's only one going at
the time sure but the same type of thing
was like the building was just
historically creepy in all the right
ways it's perfect comedy do you believe
comedy comes from darkness I think so
you think so I mean it obviously doesn't
have to but I think real good comedy has
a tendency to do so just is yours yeah
probably where's that--what's the
darkness I guess just bitterness
illustration yeah okay general I mean I
was I was curious to see you performing
the day at the belly room when we did
Flynn's show um because i always for a
while there I was always following you
yeah like a year you know it was like it
was like Rick and then Michael and it's
a super fun difficult challenge because
you you involve the audience so much and
we've talked about this I wouldn't
necessarily say it's crowd work but
there's you're going in there yeah
you're going in there but at the
building of the night you didn't do any
of that yeah very funny just written
prepared material yeah careful that
happens all the time I think podcast
it's okay I have a dog ladies and
gentlemen named Walter and the screen
almost just landed on him he's fine he's
fine um yeah mom consciously will just
leave this yeah tell me go ahead I'm
consciously trying to do material why
are you just in hopes that it might help
my career in some way because you think
you think that TV credit or whatever
could because you can't do crowd work on
TV right I've been told that lots of
times I've done in couple showcases you
know for Conan yeah tonight show that
kind of stuff now is just would say
you're really funny but we want to know
word for word what you're gonna say why
not but I think they're scared I think
it's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] cop-out yeah I
mean it would be awesome if someone came
out on late night and said oh we anybody
from Canada right BAM Canada bit you
know whatever right
I mean I don't know yeah I think it
would and you would feel comfortable to
do that for sure yeah and I feel like in
a worst-case scenario you have me do 10
minutes yeah then you edit whatever it
is you don't like out correct or you
know they have time all the time where
comics are supposed to go on and they
just they cut it for time or whatever
yep yea though record me one night she
shot ya see what happens I mean there's
do you know Ian bag yeah so Ian's a
hilarious comedian I guess you would
call him a crowd work committee a lot of
wind blown in here folks what a win um I
you know I got the sense that he was
fighting the same battle it's like I
would put him up there's one of the
funniest people in town as I would you
yet TV was always like what are we
supposed to do with you I don't know
give me anything something different
that's what I always felt yes like what
would you sit tell me about if you're
not talking about you right it could be
about anything right idea well we can
put my character in any situation um you
may be tired of answering these
questions but I haven't heard the answer
to them um so you feel like Rick Ingram
needs to start doing more written
material yeah you do yeah I mean I can't
even really get representation yeah in
this town yeah no one knows how to think
outside the box really but they've seen
you have they come and seen you some
people have some people have yeah not a
lot but who got you passed at The Comedy
Store meaning you got yourself best but
who kind of helped you and pushed you in
well I was uh I got a job as a doorman
their love and so I went in kind of the
old school way yep and uh what explain
that to people the way that Comedy Store
used to be is pretty much all the jobs
were handled by comedians and it was a
way of kind of like giving you an in at
the same time completely illegally
amusing exactly what other what other
industry would that be allowed I want to
be a buh ray exactly and they they
actually got they paid hourly now when i
worked there you got 25 bucks a night
Jesus and you were right eight hour
shift you said it was just the deal but
it was like this is the way to get in
and I was young and I didn't care yeah I
was 21 years old sure enough but that
was two thousand two or that was
yeah okay got it yeah and I just I
didn't worked at a crappy restaurant as
a waiter during the day and I work at
The Comedy Store at night they wouldn't
let me work phone shifts the comedy
store because they felt had about
attitude and after your door guy
security which which makes a lot of yeah
so and then you would work your way up
through Sunday the monday night shows
yeah you do the open mics and um back
then Mitzi was still around sure and she
would make you showcase to be a doorman
oh my god so uh I got hired she was a
showcase gravity yeah you're not
showcasing dormant cells yeah they don't
give two [ __ ] about that yeah she just
wants to know like if you don't if you
didn't realistically have a chance at
ever being a comedian she would not
allow you to work there okay so
originally it was you had to showcase
and then if she liked you you could work
the door but she wasn't around as much
at this point so they gave me a job and
they're like at some point she's going
to come in and do showcases and you're
gonna have to showcase for your job
Jesus Christ so I worked there for
probably about six months and then she
came in one night she did to pass she
came in a couple times but there was one
night where there wasn't she stuck
around longer and it's like all right
we're gonna put up more people and she
came that night to pass Ari Shaffir got
it um he had showcased like a Garry
Shandling number of times precious like
what 40 showcases she got no but she is
not ready yeah yeah I'm doing Tommy
sorry it's the same thing um so yeah she
came in pass re and re went up did great
she passed him yep and she passed Kirk
Fox that night ok and then they went
through i want to say six or seven
comics and it was not good would she
pass him immediately yeah she passed him
pretty I mean I that was Kirk's for a
showcase like know what I mean is oh
yeah sure gets off stage yeah Jesus she
sits at the back chair right by the back
door so you in order to leave you have
to walk by her and this is the ax do our
neyo are ya and she's literally holding
up I mean she's not holding a thumb up
but she's literally saying come here and
talk to me if you if
she passed you she would call you over
she's and if uh she didn't pass you but
didn't hate you she just would ignore
you right and if she really hated you
she'd call you over and basically tell
you to get out yeah just go there's
something beautiful about a dictatorship
you know like I when it works in your
favor great right but it's like what
else works like this yeah razy it's an
exchange of insane system yeah um yes I
wasn't even supposed to showcase okay
and then a bunch of people other door
guys basically went into hiding yep and
the guy who was hosting that night came
to the back door where I was stuck
working right and just said I can't find
so-and-so and so-and-so until it so
you're next grace like oh ok but this is
why you took the $25 yeah exactly this
is it um and so that they told you know
they set me up you know you're
showcasing for your job and you know you
know I think I was doing five minutes or
something so this is like saying to the
field goal kicker like don't miss the
kick yeah it's like the games on a lot
yeah everything I don't need you I know
that yeah I don't wear what this means
yeah the scary lady is sitting in there
yeah so I went up and back then this is
in the really dark period of crowds sure
there was probably eight or nine people
in the crowd and about 20 comics
seasoning around just judging and of
course yeah no one judges harder than
comics that are angry that you have the
opportunity and they don't right yeah
and a lot of the open mic or there that
night were guys that I did open mic with
and they weren't happy with the fact
that I got a job and they didn't they're
supportive of you until you have a
little success any sort exactly yeah see
I went up and acted like dumb ass did my
normal thing which was material or I
mean sorry yeah I'm not trying to be
disrespectful when I say that like oh
yeah what were you jumping into the
crowd or were no no no that wasn't for a
couple years okay I did material I uh
ace do impressions and no she's terrible
I used to do impressions that's how i
started i started comedy in kansas city
and all i did was impressions okay but
uh is that where you grew up yeah okay
and where was your first comedy set stay
in
her son's it was close yeah I've heard
wonderful things about that owner yeah
he's not a complete psychopath at all I
mean people literally you mentioned that
Club and they're like just so you know
the owners a crazy person yeah he my
first paying gig was a fifteen dollar MC
said on like a Wednesday sure after I
opened the show he brought me a a you
want to do the payout now okay whatever
you want the money you want it coke shut
up Isaac how much is fifteen dollars
okay you can sell it like a [ __ ] this is
real yeah there were stories of this
stuff yes I never heard that it actually
that actually [ __ ] happen what is
fifteen dollars of coke he didn't even
cut it out cuz I was just I mean I
assume it's like a Kibo may by myself I
just like just give me the cash yeah
sure yeah yes are you sure yeah he's uh
he's a kind of a nightmare but that's
fun he's amusing as long as you're
looking at it from outside correct it's
just when you need him to pay you for
like a weekend nah man he's like listen
uh I know we agreed on three grand but
how about 750 bucks no thank you no I
don't think that's a good deal at all Oh
interesting comedy club owners
everywhere yeah uh uh so that started it
with you you did your set and maybe I so
I I did my said it was fine yeah it
wasn't great wasn't terrible it was a
lot better than I feared it might be so
I walked offstage and was just really
hoping to not get the the old lady
finger your fire you're no good at this
um but she called me over told me to sit
down next to her and black then Duncan
was the assistant talent coordinator
Duncan Trussell no [ __ ] yeah god it's
funny you know one thing that's so funny
about the comedy store is those the the
people that had those jobs actually
became funny comedians a lot a lot of
clubs you go and that guy you know they
did comedy but they never were good at
comedy right they never got good like
here to hear the Duncan was assistant
talent corner as urz is yeah and as
bizarre I mean but but they're actually
accomplished super funny yeah absolutely
very interesting yeah yeah so don't get
moved over and I said
next to Mitzi and whoever was next on
the showcase already was back on stage
she was just having a loud conversation
as if that wasn't happened and that
person is probably dying to have Mitzi
watch her yeah probably been waiting
here a long time she's talked to me
about where I'm from how Midwest comics
are great yay good I like that she just
said basically you know you need more
stage do you need to be going up more
yep yeah but you're funny and whatever I
was like okay I didn't she didn't
specifically say like your past she sure
told me I was great and thanks for
showcasing whatever I go yeah thank you
thank you ran just like okay I gotta get
out of here and then Duncan came back
and was like man that was great Mitzi
past you and I just thought oh so you
didn't really officially get like your
pass until Duncan told ya Duncan told me
like maybe half an hour later then I
just assumed he was [ __ ] with me of
course cuz I was the young guy and horse
all the other employees [ __ ] with me
all the time worse I mean the comedy
store the kind of place where you go
inside and and for a second and someone
sees your phone and snaps pictures of
their dick and sends it it's everyone in
your in your rant I mean it's the kind
of place yeah it is for sure the default
is that it's a joke yeah yeah always
always see I just didn't I didn't
believe I mean he just he's like five
minutes tried to convince me which made
it seem even more like like I'm an
[ __ ] the end then but at the end of
the night when Mitzi walked out or
whatever I had to like help her to her
car sure and uh she had I can't remember
her assistant was Mike okay Mike
something was her assistant never to be
heard from again after he got fired but
he was a comic who was one of the worst
jobs everyone always would say you could
get in real close with Mitt seeks you
had to essentially be her actual
assistant sure but as soon as she
disliked you you were banished forever
oh god damn it right so it's uh yeah
exactly so this guy Mike was moving his
car getting his car ready to go and I
kind of helped her over to her car and
she told me to call in my avails the
next day or whatever I was like holy
[ __ ]
is real holy [ __ ] so yeah so she passed
me and then then basically didn't give
me a spot for a couple years ok I was
always there working so i just did the
late-night Poppins and your name was on
the wall yeah yeah which is which is a
big deal yeah that's a courtesy of Kurt
Fox they hadn't then painted names on
the wall like 14 years oh is that right
yeah I always assumed that that was
that's always been happening now if it
um they had done it in over a decade and
then Kirk that was much space between
some of the names yeah the slalom where
I am now it's like so what happened I
did I haven't heard this so what
happened Kirk called The Comedy Store
and he really wanted his name painted on
the wall and they were just basically
like here we don't we don't ya curtain
or row and he he offered you know he
said well pay for my name and they're
like that's not really how were there's
something that Kirk would tell me are
you telling us inside information I
think I mean I've heard Kirk talk about
audio seddie I can't wait to hear this
feels great so then they said no you
can't pay to put your own name on there
that's not how it works and then his
response was what if i pay to put all
the names up I like that they were like
okay I'd like that it's used like yeah
alright that sounds like a good deal so
they they put up like a hundred of us or
something from like it was from like
1993 2 2004 Kirk pay for it Kirk paper
god damn it yeah Mitzi yeah the offer is
all you need yeah you should still pay
for ya oh that's so [ __ ] great he did
and it was awesome and then my name is
right by the back door yep and then I
had to sit at the back door and check
IDs directly with my name do someday
Bros actually it's right there Israel er
it's such a funny I remember I would
it's such a weird dichotomy economy
because I remember like working with
[ __ ] most on the road and he was like
hilarious and funny and a man who's
crushing and then literally the next
night I see him pushing like a mop yeah
to clean up someone's puke in the
bathroom yeah god damn it's like it's
already a humbling job yeah it's it's
tough every time you're up there and it
doesn't go fantastic it's humbling yeah
yeah I get that part it'll make you yeah
I had
had a couple times where again I'd
always go up lakeside you shop in fact
in but I get offstage feeldog this dog
is I'm sorry this is the first part guys
we've done with Walter he's great he's
cute but he doesn't really he doesn't
understand that I'm allowed to give
attention to somebody else right yeah I
mean so I why he's not happy he's got a
tennis little mini tennis ball sorry go
home yeah I get off in like one in the
morning for having like a pretty decent
set for you know the ten people that
were there whatever and then immediately
get all staged someone would hand me the
mop toilets overflowing in the women's
restroom like I thought you're gonna say
hey it's this Joe could use this tag
instead it's not clean that [ __ ] up way
worse than that yeah and then like
having to watch some of the people that
you just performed for walk out and just
look at you just mop mopping a turd into
a corner uh Brian Regan tells us about
when he worked at some comedy club I
used to go up but they would also have
to take the trash out yeah so he would
see the audience as he's taking the
trash out just so humbling yeah it's
it's a terrible experience whenever I
would get whenever I would get late
spots I was into drinking beforehand
yeah I as well I was did you used to
drink yeah I just quit drinking when uh
when I found out I was diabetic okay
which which was when uh five years ago
okay just over five years ago I was sick
for a couple years but I didn't finally
I didn't officially figure out what was
actually wrong with me until five years
he was it a search to find out what was
wrong with you or you just didn't feel
well I was pretty sick all the time for
a couple years and i went to a bunch of
doctors and i didn't have health
insurance so i was spending a lot of
money and basically just getting
misdiagnosed and no one [ __ ] thought
to check you for diabetes no one no one
thought a simple prick of the finger
test would work and this is this is hold
on Walter stop what are you doing dude
I'm talking to Rick he's done by the way
sick and you're [ __ ] trying to get
your tennis ball oh sorry he was like
what's he doing get your [ __ ] sorry
everybody Jesus Christ Stephanie to hug
I'm trying to talk to Rick this is why I
wasn't sure if this was the right idea
to have the dog here but we'll live and
learn um it's a very very common yeah is
it a disease yeah it's a disease
my father's diabetic yeah if you would
think that'd be the first thing they
would check well I guess that the the
issue was i had a lot of stomach issues
ok and i throw up a lot yeah but I was
in my late 20s yep and I'm a skinny yeah
so usually people get type 2 diabetes or
heavier said we're older right and
people get type 1 diabetes or kids right
I used to call it juvenile diabetes okay
God and that's what I have you have type
1 i've type 1 which is insulin
injections yeah yeah okay that's what my
father has he got mid-20s yeah yeah ok
so i guess doctors just looked at me and
they're like you know he weighs a buck
40 right whatever I wait at the time I
was like were you a buck 40 yeah I was
pretty skinny Wow and uh see I you know
they diagnosed me with all these
ridiculous diseases one doctor
gastrointestinal knowledge 'used told me
I had intestinal migraines what the [ __ ]
I was just like oh my god that sounds
terrible and then I went home and I
googled it and it was like its disputed
whether this is a real disease great
what the [ __ ] can you tell people stuff
knowing that Google exists disputed this
is a real disease senior boozing you're
drinking at the time yeah drinking are
you were you heavy drinker yes social
it's pretty heavy drinker Comedy Store
occur yeah I mean I live two blocks from
The Comedy Store and uh I drank not
every night but close to every night but
that doesn't help the stomach no it
doesn't and there was like a year where
I quit when the stomach issue started
yep and it didn't help to you like some
I have to go back to boozing okay then
you know you get five beers in your life
I feel alright pretty good all of a
sudden go home and throw up again
there's probably just cuz the normal
stuff an odd this have been just a
terrible time of your life it was pretty
brutal you're always sick yeah man it
was terrible had a regular job that I
lost cuz i was sick so often and uh it
was it was pretty terrible and I just
didn't know what to do you know I mean
yep I go to doctors and you know they'd
always tell me something for a while
they thought I might have crow
busy yeah that they gave me medication
for that and it didn't do anything you
have no health care no yet not so every
time someone recommends you better go
see a specialist you thinking there's
only five four three yeah exactly god
damn it yeah I had to get like a upper
endoscopy at one point it was like 13
grand or something and what you do I
just kept not paying it and they called
me that God I don't have any money yeah
and eventually they they sent me a dated
bill that was like instead of 13 grand
what about like 1200 correct so I was
just like okay yeah I can do that yeah i
ended up paying that i mean i had a nose
what they charged someone else yeah rate
or ever was I had a doctor in New York
tell me because I was under the same I
wasn't sick i was getting physical
therapy which is probably the opposite
of being sick I was so healthy that I
hurt my body and then I was like getting
a shoulder but he was like when you get
a bill he's like it's not a bill it's
it's the beginning of negotiations yeah
and I'm like this is a [ __ ] doctor
telling me this yeah it's like all
racket and it's a really good it's a
[ __ ] wreck call the hall the hospital
and say I can give you this right now if
you don't take it now I'm not going to
give you this and you can start
negotiating yeah and this is health by
capitalism yeah this is [ __ ] it's
it's insanely corrupt and terrible and
it basically goes back to the doctor's
office assuming everyone has insurance
correct and so basically they're going
to try and gouge the insurance company
and the insurance company's going to do
that same exact thing they're like we're
not paying you that will give you this
just key and then they just okay yeah so
as a person you don't realize that's
what you can do yeah but it sets the
same thing it's like they're just trying
they'll charge the maximum amount for
anything they can't erectus and assume
that the insurance company whose
charging ridiculous premiums will have
the money to pay it whatever it is what
would you tell someone in your situation
who is not feeling well is sick clearly
sick and doesn't have insurance what
would you tell someone listening to that
ahead i don't know i mean was it good to
not pay all that [ __ ] and just say [ __ ]
you i'm not paying yeah i mean in the
end it's screwed up that's all you could
do but once I figured out that was the
deals like oh
yeah yeah and you know you still end up
paying Tom I still end up having to pay
several thousand dollars over a couple
years whatever was but it's way better
than the thirty-five thousand dollar
right I was initially built for all
these random doctors and specialists and
stuff my ex-girlfriend was it was German
still is German just not my girlfriend
uh and got while living in Los Angeles
had an appendectomy right guy
appendicitis tennis Ida so she gets her
bill and it's like 36 grand and I was
overnight stay about all this [ __ ]
so we go for the checkup interview
interview consultation and they send in
a financial counselor wit to first talk
to her and say your insurance isn't
covering this and I'm here to like
console you yeah be a professional I'm
sorry person basically like he'd be
great if you'd pay it all exact like and
it was just like whoa this is our system
anyways the insurance did cover there's
no problem at all but I was fascinating
to see that they literally send in like
a social worker that's like you want a
hug this is gonna suck yeah what [ __ ]
up when I when I eventually found out I
was diabetic and this is my worst
birthday great great um we get there
eventually yeah well that's what I was
gonna ask you is what first of all when
is your birthday my birthday is April 24
April 24 ok and you like this time of
year for birthday yeah that's all you
know always enjoyed yeah i mean is
towards the end of school year yeah so I
as a kid when birthdays really mean
something I could I still got to bring
treats and we are already basically it's
almost summer modes yeah yeah everyone
is pretty happy I mean Kansas City if
it's anything like Michigan it's like
April May are pretty sweet yeah yes this
winter is it ended up you get two months
in the spring and two months of the fall
the rest of the years are [ __ ] hot
humid or freezing in here the city is so
[ __ ] hot yeah I mean those july i
used to play a tennis tournament in the
city center there that like oh yeah that
it is the ambulance was coming so often
these are professional athletes yeah the
ambulance was coming so it just stayed
yes this was an ambulance it was like
heat exhaustion heat strokes crazy
yeah I ran cross-country in high school
because I was a baller here but uh like
the first two races of the year was
basically a at least ten percent of the
race is gonna pass bassinets
august/september yeah Jesus yeah there's
always like we can just survive until
just of all don't collapse yeah we will
be ok alright so April 24th yeah and so
that's a good time yeah now when you're
older in life you're sick and tell me
tell me what happened as I was
approaching my 30th birthday I was I was
as sick as I'd ever been like way sicker
than the normal and I mean my previous
couple years of illness was like I would
throw up probably eight to nine times a
week Wow like always sick and there'd be
like three or four days where I'd be
fine after eating or just just it kind
of didn't really there was no real
pattern to it yeah and uh like I went to
New York with Bobby Lee one time yeah
and we did Caroline's and I was sick the
whole week and no idea why do you
perform I would I was hosting so I would
go up host go backstage lay down on the
concrete floor in the green room
bathroom yep for whatever reason the
coolness would kind of calm me down make
me feel a little better then I would get
up and go back out and bring up someone
to go back and lay down on the floor and
Bobby with respect what do you you can't
die cuz people are gonna blame me for
this do we get a sold out late you can't
die yeah isn't it weird though when
you're not feeling well and you were
obviously sick but when you get on stage
somehow your body kind of pushes through
it it was the only time during it any
day where I felt good was the adrenaline
kind of yet took over and I just I
didn't feel sick at all when I was on
stage and for about 30 minutes after a
set if you i'll have like diarrhea on
the road sure and I'll go on stage and
I'll be like how am I gonna get through
this yeah for an hour I'm great fine and
you get off stage and it's [ __ ] right
out actually it's so weird yeah okay so
you're 30 you're so about to turn 30
yeah I'm approaching 30 and I'm getting
real sick at this point I start losing a
lot of weight how much are you puking
you said you were puking 82 times a week
at this point I'm throwing up
well every day that's this it's got to
be terrible and yes it just feels awful
I throw up mouth all the time yep oh
Jesus yeah and uh I'm sorry if I'm
making a real if this no it's all good
so for like about a month ahead of my
30th birthday I guess I get real sick
and I at this point I've done a couple
TV commercials and I have sag health
insurance Joe nice so I'm like finally
know at least I can go see a doctor now
and I'm not going to have to pay for all
of it and so I i called the SAG clinic
up in burbank or whatever it is an
Eastern on these [ __ ] yeah
they're like well the first point what
we have is on April 24th on my birthday
your birthday I'm like okay and like
that it's about 27 days away or
something into March at this point but
I'm just like okay will do that's fine
yep that's as soon as I can get that I
mean is that is that by the way the
doorbell rings in my apartment three
times in two years and it's always been
during a podcast what the [ __ ] whole lot
that was awesome by the way what was
awesome the just leaned out the window
hey it's michael i'm doing a pocket only
of course an outlet hey i'm doing a
podcast anybody of the [ __ ] delivery
it's a delivery um I'm sorry about this
cheese wheel or Walter we got office
depot this is why it's nice to have a
studio you hear those people that want a
[ __ ] sponsor this thing so why didn't
you go the emergency room oh cuz it you
know I've been sick for so long that
point it just seemed like okay well you
know whatever it is yeah it can wait
it's not gonna get better and you needed
a specialist probably if some guy did a
stomach this is pacifically stomach yeah
it was stomach issues and and that's
kind of what I was seeing but no one
ever tells you when you're growing up
that a doctor basically knows whatever
he specializes in her and nothing else
right and like if you go to like a
general practitioner it basically just
means they have no expertise on anything
other than like you have the flu take
some tamiflu I throat here's some
antibiotics I always hate that I don't
know what kind of doctrine supposed to
go to
literally google like what is a shoulder
pain doctor right because general
practitioner is just gentle but that but
but they never solved the problem ever
ever ever yeah they're correct they very
clearly can solve like the four simplest
yeah illnesses yep and it's always an
antibiotic or some sort of anti-nausea
medication so I set up the thing at the
sag clinic because I told me I'd have to
see them get a recommendation from them
on here we go for I go to a specialist
for a sag to cover it whatever was yeah
and uh so I kept getting sicker and
sicker than that and that time from when
I set up the appointment until the
appointment on my birthday happy
birthday I lost about 35 pounds one
month yeah 24 for 25 days yeah i went
from wild 140 145 to like just under 120
are you serious and I'm I'm just under
six foot tall so I mean I was looking
like Holocaust victim your bars like I'm
still performing I go The Comedy Store
and like two nights before uh you know
Oh for like a week leading up to it
people were starting to get fairly
concerned someone told me now and I
forget who it was maybe it was the night
I asked you to do this but someone said
like when Rick was sick there was a time
when when we had to like say to to him
hey man this is getting bad yeah yeah
they were you must have known yeah I
mean I knew someone's going on just the
weight loss was kind of a big thing but
like you know I'm googling all
throughout this trying to figure out it
basically you just always have cancer
right that's my feel like I probably
have stomach cancer and my body's not
you know taking nutrients in because the
tumor so big or whatever are you are you
able to eat a little bit yeah but I mean
it's been a couple years I just can't
eat that much ever because I get so sick
it's a sick and cancers always crazy
because we don't even know what cancer
is anyways it's like cancer justice that
this word we use yeah just means they're
super I thought a ton of different types
of add more net that abnormal to say so
you're convinced that there's some shits
bad yeah and then boom shakalaka the
transient salesman at the comedy store
much mediately this is this is
he's not home I don't know if he's
homeless knowing those yeah he sells
Records and books and paintings he comes
by The Comedy Store a great character
yeah totally bizarre weird guy but
definitely looks like a transient sure
and he came up and he said Rick Ingram
you look like you got AIDS and I was
like man life is not good that's not
good uh would there be any chance you
had AIDS not that I know of yeah I mean
there shouldn't be yeah but I'm on you
hadn't [ __ ] some no I didn't hit her
somewhere not a condom and you know I
mean there there wasn't any sort of
suspicious drug use or whatever no no
okay no no I mean I smoke pot but that
was a shootout yeah we should go that's
a sure did it cross your mind with did
that scare you when he said that I mean
I was already pretty freaked out yeah
but like hearing now is just follow
those things was like I got it I got to
do something especially from him yeah
it's like I mean it basically everyone
was kind of saying stuff to me about it
yeah Jade que de prado it's like you
look terrible yes thank you thank you j
for me yeah yeah no I'm you she was by
working there that yes okay all right
that's just I guess I am aware of a
doctor's appointment a couple days ago
that's tough in a PDC yeah he was he's a
buddy of mine and he was just start
yelling at people he's like he knows he
can't leave the [ __ ] alone thank you so
on the on my birthday that's my 30th
birthday are you date you dating anyone
at this time are you yeah I've been with
my wife for probably two and a half
three years at that point I was dating
okay just weren't married a marriage
bill just ugh so and what year was this
this would have been 2011 okay so fairly
recent yeah okay and I went to the wow
she's really dealing with a lot too yeah
she she she's my boyfriend is [ __ ]
not feeling well yeah I our third date
was me projectile vomiting the Chinese
food we ate her just being like no it's
cool this is cool i really care for this
well that's amazing yeah that's stuck
around so yeah that's amazing um yes I
go the sack
linic and you know I'm thinking supposed
to see some doctor named dr. Rose I'm
thinking this guy sounds legit I thought
I'd be good doctor heroes it's your 30th
birthday 30th birthday and so I get in
there and I'm amann ciated and pail are
you excited you're probably I know like
even minor health problems I've had when
I finally get to the doctor I'm excited
like maybe this can be fit this KJ yet
this is help yes so yeah so I get to the
doctor and I'm kind of giving him my
rundown of what's going on and at this
point I had the added effect beyond the
throwing up of I'm drinking water
non-stop that's what I was going to ask
his typical symptoms you have becoming a
diabetic yeah like the last two weeks of
that I'm drinking a lot of water I have
to go to the bathroom all the time tons
of water yeah like gallons of water
non-stop so you can't quench your thirst
yeah no matter what if I drank a full
liter of water I want another leader
within 10 minutes and the end this is a
because my father told me the same thing
and it used to scare the [ __ ] out of me
when I was a kid yeah cuz I be if I was
thirsty it's like of course I have
diabetes you know but for some reason
it's because I don't know what I don't
get it I don't understand why you of
when you when you're not converting
carbs into energy sure your body starts
putting a thing called ketones in your
blood and it's very bad for your body
and so the excessive amounts of water is
an attempt of your body to flush out the
ketone interesting and so I get to the
doctor and I kind of explain it to him
and and he's this he's probably early
30s black dude braids down low mid back
I mean I'm am i judging yes I'm judging
sorry you don't exactly expect your diet
I was judging more off the age yeah I
want a [ __ ] expert here yeah not a
guy to just graduate from yeah yes very
clearly knew at least to the profession
of be a doctor and he's a general
practitioner on top of it and it's sag
on top of it is cheap best doctor yeah
yeah so he takes checks my blood sugar
first person to do it then he's like
okay first doctor to check your blood
sugar yeah
out of all these things are it takes 30
seconds yeah i mean i could if someone
would have suggested it to me i could
have gone to CVS on your own paid thirty
dollars and got a tester and some
testing stress he's and if you know I
blame the comedy store too can somebody
there stop ordering shots of Jameson and
[ __ ] know this anybody somebody
should have gone hey bro check your
[ __ ] blood yeah baby yeah yeah um so
he checks your blood sugar and then he
just he says uh you know what I think I
think he might be diabetic um I want to
do a 12-hour fasting blood test so
tonight don't eat anything after eight
o'clock what was your blood sugar level
do remember he didn't tell me oh [ __ ]
and I wouldn't have known that one
anyways that he didn't say anything he
just told me thought I was diabetic and
so don't anything after eight or nine
o'clock I don't know what it was and
then come in tomorrow 12 hours after
that what does that accomplish it just
gives you a I guess a more accurate
reading no no food yeah no food to raise
it okay so whatever you're standing
blood sugar level would be I suppose
it's just picturing you fat have them
fast at your birthday yeah no birthday
cake no [ __ ] celebrate okay again
it's kind of like you said it's like you
know what maybe this maybe well he'll be
the process to be getting help yeah so i
went home and just kind of dealt with it
felt sick for the day and ate dinner we
know whatever before the time frame he
wanted me to eat no spot that night no
spot and at that point I was kind of
avoiding the comedy store just cuz I
didn't want hear about how sick I look
Jayd kind of product look like I yeah
Amanda and then about midnight or so it
got really sick and one of the things
that would kind of help calm me down
from throwing up excessively was I would
take either really hot showers or a hot
bath okay and it was just kind of like
taking like like an athlete going in the
hot tub it just relaxes your muscles and
whatever it is and there's also you also
have a lot of probably mental anxiety
yeah
just what I'm just happening to me I
haven't felt great i mean there's like
only dead like that yeah exactly right
um and so i basically i would get in the
shower took a shower and then got out
felt sick immediately so I ran filled
the bathtub up took a bath I felt fine
not great but I felt fine was in the
bath and I'll a bath like an hour and
then I got out got sick and someone with
use your girlfriend with you she's
asleep okay and cuz I'm you know I'm
trying not to bother examples my issues
whatever it is which I've got a feeling
rick is maybe something that that's
something you're in your personality
yeah it's Midwest as well yeah hey don't
worry about my bloody head over here I'm
fine yes correct um so I stayed in the
bathtub from essentially midnight until
about six thirty in the morning no [ __ ]
just filling it up with hot water
getting back in it and in the morning my
my girlfriend's alarm chiots she goes to
work really early so her long got off
went off little before six whatever you
spent your 30th birthday night in the
bathtub a whole night yeah refilling it
with hot water did she is obviously
weren't concerned about the drought no
no this is pretty dry out it wasn't i
wasn't keen on the drought situation i
might have caused the drought that Jesus
um but she came in she's like what are
you doing you okay I was like oh fine
yeah and she was like you're not fine
yeah we need to go the hospital i'm like
it's fine i gotta go to the doctor's
office in a few minutes or whatever at
eight o'clock she's like i have taken
off work I'm gonna take you to the SAG
clinic yeah I'm demanding that we don't
know the emergency room right so she
takes money fear fear of money and also
the five hour away yeah this is going to
be
nightmare so she takes in a sack clinic
and I'm still sick I can't even they
can't even draw my blood just so
dehydrated from throwing up so Jen so is
that dr. there they had me going with a
different doctor yeah and the doctors
like you know tell me what's going on
Mike well dr. Rose said that he thought
I'm just putting this doctor on blast
poor guy uh he said he's a he's a big
listen he said well he was the first one
to baby even do what that was helpful
yeah um and I said he'd only told me
yesterday thinks I might be diabetic but
I can't they can't take my blood they
can't find a vein or whatever it is and
then he just opens my charts and he's
goes yeah you need to go to the
emergency room immediately I was like
really i don't i don't know that my
insurance covers that and he's like all
insurance covers that yeah some
insurance only covers that right you
don't have a choice even if this costs
you everything you own you need to go
the emergency room Wow looks like oh
okay wow so my wife drives me an
emergency so don't know what your blood
sugar level was no I find out later from
calling just getting my records turn
into my endocrinologist that it was 470
Wow should never be above 150 Wow so in
theory doctorow should have been like
you need to go the emergency room right
now right then that's too high yeah I
mean they say so d in when you ever been
diagnosed yet it's possible it was that
high for very long periods of time yeah
and then uh I'll come back to this but
the all my stomach issues or from
ketoacidosis which is all just a side
effect of high blood sugar so I probably
had a blood sugar over 200 to 300 for a
couple years four years yeah and like
basically my pancreas was shutting down
Shirin completely shut down yet still
producing some insulin and God it maybe
feel better then yeah worse oh my okay
so so so I go to the emergency were so
happy your girlfriend took the day off
yeah
to copy too we get to the emergency room
and there's there's no wait we get there
and they just have a wheelchair waiting
for me my doctor had called ahead whoa
valet you need to take care of this guy
before he dies today that's probably
when you also knew [ __ ] i'm actually
sick yeah this isn't a good sign at all
at this point i could barely walk that's
how bad it has gotten no show my muscles
are so weak that I'm just like my
girlfriend's helping me off that helped
me into the doctor's office like I just
sprained my ankle to basketball right
right right thing except you sprained
your pancreas four years ago uh uh is is
this shock is this just the body is like
reaching its final yes pages I mean
basically what's happening is my my body
is producing so much excessive stomach
acid mmm an intent to burn any car by
putting my body into basically waste
right and so our body does have a
emergency yeah man it's just we can
always just not it'll help momentarily
but that's just not a right long-term
long-term plan so you're barely being
able to walk the wheelchairs their valet
service they take me straight into the
ICU and hook me up which hospital see
st. josephs where burbank burbank okay
to shuts a fun time of every time you
drive by that thing yeah it's nice
somebody on the 134 oh hey when my life
was fine when I spent I spent three days
in the ICU more days in the hospital
after that within an hour they sent in
an endocrinologist who's still my
endocrinologist what is it would is
endocrinology it's a doctors who
specialize in diabetes metabolism and
thyroids does he got it and he just
basically said you know you're diabetic
we just looked at your blood results and
you have antibodies in your blood that
have been attacking your pancreas which
means you have type 1 diabetes yeah yeah
you know your blood sugar is off the
charts your a1c which is basically an
average of three month the last three
months of
your blood sugar was uh hitting me a
chart and went from five to 13 and a
half he's like yours would be about 15.3
but it's not going to show up on this
chart and show up on the [ __ ] chart
we have the hospital chart so Jesus so
when you're when you go in and you're
this bad do they can they inject you
with insulin right away or would that
even be a problem or like Leia did they
make you feel better right away no I
feel sick for as long as I was in the
ICU I felt terrible he'll say basically
they were were giving me insulin but my
body was just so wrecked yeah that point
there I mean I was on a morphine drip
for three days just sure that I wouldn't
be an agony dude I'm gonna blow I'm
gonna I'm gonna share this with like
diabetic groups and stuff too because
this is important for people to hear ya
I mean this got [ __ ] terrible yeah I
mean it's bad my doctor was basically
like you're here like a week away from
your body shutting dad just saying about
this I'm just and he's he's your guy now
yeah he's great I love that yeah because
he's seen you it brought me back
confront underworld exactly yeah there's
a brief period where they he didn't
accept he moved to a different clinic or
whatever and he works for UCLA a medical
company now whatever it is and there was
a brief time where they didn't accept
sag insurance and I was just panic
England yeah what am I gonna do need
this guy so I waited I waited like six
months until I needed to go see a doctor
again whatever and refill my
prescriptions and called his office to
try and get stuff transferred and
they're like oh no will we accept your
insurance nails like thank oh god it's
huge um so you still still my
endocrinologist okay my wife actually
has a thyroid issue so he's her doctor
as well now go so it's all worth it for
him yeah let's get that extra he's
making a lot of time off the Ingraham
family so so three days later I start
feeling better but all my my numbers
were still off so they kept me two more
days at the hospital is this a less nice
room are they teaching you how to be a
diabetic then as well yeah they're kind
of show
me basically how it works were you
scared about where you were you happy
you knew was going on were you
disappointed were you sad um I was I was
really depressed about it yeah just
because it's like one of those things
where you know you're in you're in my
head I just I couldn't got like why is
this happening to me yeah and I didn't I
didn't understand at the time fully that
my all my illness is for the last couple
of years is completely connected to this
sure so now i'm thinking like so now I
gotta deal with this on top of feeling
sick stomach is shitty and I'm a
diabetic yeah you know you're not
drawing the conclusion yeah and uh I
just I really felt sorry for myself more
or less sure just kind of all those
things was like I felt like I needed to
cry all the time yeah like I know all
these fat people I know negativo ever
they want rafi may it's the [ __ ] tour
the country okay exactly yeah yeah so
I'm just really frustrated with it and
then uh and then you know they're
teaching me how to get myself shots and
stuff really freaked me out I've always
been a you know just really scared of
needles chef guy sure not anymore
obviously yeah so so you inject now yeah
I do i do at least four shots every day
yep Jana I test my blood sugar four or
five times a day and I eat really
healthy now I mean I had a pretty
standard comedian died attend or sure
you know I need a lot chicken fingers so
many tickets uh fry Bob garbage yeah and
probably ten beers yeah even if it's for
beers it's like you too many beers yeah
way too many beers yeah which is just
glucose yeah right then your body turn
everybody turns it yet yeah everything
just turns into carbs yeah and
everything sugar yeah you know like over
the years before I found out i'm
thinking you know i got to eat something
kind of healthy and so I'm like making
myself pasta stuff yeah just killing my
body even worse yeah well you know yeah
yeah and I just didn't you know I mean
by the time I got out of the hospital I
had a pretty decent understanding a
crash course sure basically this is what
your life is going to look like Helen
say I got out and when did you start to
feel better about maybe two weeks after
okay I had a lot of really weird kind of
things happen to me after I got out in
terms of like my body adjusting and
stuff like I've had glasses since I was
in the fourth grade yep and for whatever
reason for two weeks after I got out of
hospital I my eyesight was perfect crazy
like I couldn't if I put my glasses on
and it was like when you wear contacts
and glasses but your body's [ __ ]
healing itself yeah is like a Wolverine
kind of yeah and then uh and then went
my eyesight went back to being bad but
not as bad as it had been um so I had to
get new words I insurance either they
gotta go [ __ ] do this right um yeah
so that was his kind of his arse like
two weeks I didn't really do anything I
her a spot at the Laugh Factory I went
did that cuz it was one of those you
know thoughts like if I missed it we're
so gonna punish me I mean that every
comic sits in his chair and they tell me
some fucked-up story about their life
and then they're like but I had to do a
spot so we're going I'm like no dude
take care your wife just said she wants
a divorce you Jeff Tate stop booking
shows the enemy lays a [ __ ] problem
man yeah yeah but we're just it's
whatever it is yeah and in my mind I'm
like I'm gonna go if I have a great show
then I'm gonna start getting regular
spots there again right right but Dad I
just went basically still sick as [ __ ] I
had to have someone drive me there cuz I
my eyes were so adjusting that exact one
comfortable driving it right right I
just had like the most average said ever
no one was there often was there anyway
there's no difference he made fifteen
dollars ya ever was yeah [ __ ] yes oh
then about two weeks after that I felt
normal mm-hmm I mean I felt better than
I'd Felton was that is great that's
great and then I feel like 3-4 months
after that it's just like I felt awesome
I was very happy it's just like holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] and I'm up all of this is
gone now gone I haven't thrown up once
since I got out of the hospital dead and
saying um it's just yeah I mean I eat
really healthy now you have tables yeah
most of the time like what my diet
consists of okay yeah and and and you're
I mean is there anything that it limits
you and doing besides maybe eating
chocolate cake all the time yeah
can't eat some things that's pretty much
the main limitation I mean and no
stomach problems now none and you feel
good yeah feel feel healthy sharp
mentally yeah way better I mean it I was
so terrified of becoming a diabetic when
I was a kid because my dad um you know
he was like any for kids family work
blah blah blah and every once in a while
he would get low sugar yep and he would
turn into kind of a weird person like he
would kind of I wouldn't say aggressive
but he would just kind of bark and and
that was not my dad that yet that
happens to me that was the yeah so my
wife will be like check your budget a
bug and so-and-so weeds have this rule
in our house where was like cuz was
something that was weird about it was
when we would say dad we think your
blood Sugar's low when he would have low
blood sugar here we go no it's not it's
fine yeah and I fine but we knew when he
would argue with us that it was those
right everywhere I go through the same
thing okay so anyways as a ten-year-old
that scared the [ __ ] outta me sure I was
so afraid of becoming diabetic and then
my dad he just he managed it he turned
to switch he managed it wonderfully he
has since then and I'm baffled that he
can he completely full life I mean it
doesn't yes he's gotta eat every once
awhile he's gonna take a shot he's gotta
manage it but or he does everything he
wants to do yeah I don't I don't feel
any sort of restrictions I mean I don't
eat dessert but yeah that's okay I can
live without that and uh probably better
anyways yeah I'm definitely way
healthier yeah yeah I don't drink
anymore I very rarely crap sure you know
every once in a while I'll be a man
screw it I'm gonna get myself a little
more insulin and yeah chicken fingers
and french fries you can adjust that way
yeah yeah and I can deal that with that
and I have no complications from it or
EMS booze sometimes when I'm at when I'm
at the comedy store I miss it yeah and
especially on like a friday night yeah
everyone up there is just hammered yeah
and like everyone so wasted and it's
just really frustrating just like man I
don't want to it is fun and I can't
aren't you know Argus Hamilton sure he's
a he's sober it's over 20 28 years 30
year
whatever it is now and when I first got
out of the hospital and I came back you
know I one of the comedy stores you know
word got around or whatever people were
very supportive and yeah and uh no no
one told you check your [ __ ] blood
sugar but I was supportive when you come
back yeah yes like oh he was in the
hospital and he's got diabetes you know
you don't have the cancer yeah he
doesn't have AIDS boom shakalaka so I
came back and I mean I if I was at The
Comedy Store I pretty much always had a
Budweiser in my hand sure always sure so
when I came back I saw Argus and he said
you know hey rich i want to talk to you
if you got a minute always calls me rich
I don't know why it's a great artist and
fresh thanks yeah say he pulls me aside
after his dad or whatever and he's just
like heard you you had to quit drinking
I said yeah you know just for now doctor
said i could probably have some beers if
i wanted you know in a couple years I'll
take it under control but I probably
won't do that just cuz i'm more of a
drink a lot of beers not a couple beers
kind of guy with you and he said well
you should come to a with me yeah yeah
I'm good damn you know i just got a
hospital and this isn't like i need to
stop this because in alcohol wasn't what
got me in hospital it wasn't yeah yeah
it was just like I'm not I'm not you
know yelling at my girlfriend correct
wasted so I need to get a control of my
life too right I just can't be doing
this and he said well you're one of the
lucky ones i wish i would have had a
health scare that would have made me
where it's like okay you did it's called
alchemy and it's with you [ __ ] had oh
yeah it's called abusing the owner
comedy club I usually yeah when you got
too wasted but uh that's funny yeah so
then after that it's been good yeah i
mean argus is one of these guys that
he's there to help when people want yeah
people want help you know that's funny
but he also probably saw you know a
little bit of himself in you blah blah
blah but for you it was that you had
unmanaged you were on you were untagged
i was a diabetic yeah yeah that's fun
that was my my issue did anybody sing
you happy birthday the 30th know
now it it was and because I've been sick
for so long in my mind is literally just
like a this is this what getting older
side this is I'm almost 30 it doesn't
have to be like that this is just yet a
pee more it makes sense you'd be all you
gotta drink water all the time I'm 30
that's the 30 is um what is I always
like to finish with this and that is
what is a great birthday that you've had
that can come it comes to mind you know
at any experience you've had my 25th
birthday okay was by far my most
glorious I was a been in the comedy
store a couple years and I was pretty
much up there almost every night and I
didn't have a spot that night but I went
up there just cuz it was my birthday
again I live two blocks away and also
people that don't know the comedy store
it's it's such a community yeah it's a
community of it's a fraternity of every
yeah I mean every sexuality gender race
uh and I don't want to say degenerates
cuz that cuz but you just have
everything there's a lot of degenerate
okay say no but there are but but not
everybody is right now because I don't
want to be yeah but it's like uh there's
the janitors rich there's poor there's
and it's just a big club house of
[ __ ] fun yeah there's there's lots of
Merryman people drinking yes we're in
pot correct do whatever they want
everyone back in the dollars all time
all they're probably still lots of coke
there's still lots of coke but it's not
from what i understand it used to just
be I wasn't saying mountains Thunder
bumps every minute oh yeah so I went up
there my 25th and about ten thirty or so
I was probably about four or five beers
here and staying at the back door and
back then I used to do it there was
about five solid years where I would
just get drunk and turn into drunk argus
that was my care funny argus yeah i just
did argus as if it purse was just me
being argus making fun of him sure and
then Johnny Carson died and i started
doing drunk argus as if Argost went off
the wagon so upset the Harrison Carson
died and so and then like that time that
died sister doing argus notion being
like hey August so what year do you
think it is I know it's 1984 I'm ready
to party
you're crazy August that's fun so like
I'd be up there and people just even if
I was just being normally be like hey
Argus and then just mainly going to it I
was a young comic that just loved the
attention in the den whadda ya people
think I was funny or whatever stay on
the back door and I went into the back
bar and got another beer and then walked
out the hallway and Dean the old manager
was hurling there I don't do so I
started talking to Dean and I look over
and Robin Williams walked in what I'm
just kind of standing at the bottom of
the steps the o.r looking in and then
dean is like hey it's Robin Williams
like I got this Dean and he's like no
duh I was already already halfway down
the hallway I just walked out to him and
I said hey Robin the Todd's looking for
you he said you own 1,800 bucks for that
8-ball and uh Robin just looked all
shocks and then started laughing he goes
what I said the Todd is looking for you
and he just goes running out of the
hallway I'm like oh that's not good
running back here he's like how the hell
you know I bought coke from in the 80s
oh my god that's great so well there's a
photo of you guys hanging up he's like
are you Argus Hamilton and I started
kind of messing with them and he just
nearly jumped on then a group surrounded
us and we went to the back bar someone
was like hey Chi birthday and we get
your shot he's like it's your birthday
let's do shots so now I'm walking to the
back bar with Robin Williams and we're
doing shots of tequila and there's
probably 20 people surrounding us and
like four people in the o.r watching the
down a bit bigger audience in there so
we we basically did Robin and drunk our
guest for like two hours we did about
six shots of tequila sure when smoked a
couple joints oh man I just love it it
like this is so great yeah uh you know
I'm running through his whole career
telling them how all of its garbage and
it's never gonna work as drunk art as
drug this this this TV show about the
alien no one's gonna watch that crap
that's pretty pretty popular artists no
one's gonna watch no season two not a
chance now and he's it he was just
loving we went I went on stage and he
came and was yelling stuff at me
I mean this is its intoxicating the
energy of this place on a good night
it's intoxicating without the booze
without the drugs whatever it's just
thick moments like this yeah it's a
special moment yes and then uh you know
he gave me advice about comedy and I was
doing crowd worked in he's telling me
you know just keep doing it you can
either that's awesome do what everyone
else does and you know get bit parts on
sitcoms from time to time or you can be
you and have a chance at being the star
of whatever you wanna be a star with it
whatever they can yeah exactly and still
haven't achieved anything that I mean
it's been 10 years that son of a [ __ ]
but they must why kill themselves yes
terrible about that yeah so then end of
that night uh you know he it was like I
haven't haven't been this [ __ ] up in a
Long Knives likes that's a sad thought
he was like sober even yeah baby was he
was yeah he had apparently started
drinking a couple weeks before that like
a little bit here and there yeah but
this night we just got wasted and so the
next next good I guess yeah yeah maybe
the next night Don Berra saw me and was
like hey that was pretty cool last night
i was telling Kimmel about it and and he
seemed kind of disturbed because you
know Robins been sober for like 15 20
years and I was like really 15 20 years
yeah and so then let him just kind of
feeling a little bad like i mean he he
asked me yeah your fault but and then
maybe within a month of my birthday
Robin Williams checked into rehab yeah
it was just like you know I've been
partying again it's wrong and it wasn't
you did yeah but it wasn't [ __ ] you I
mean I saw I saw him like a year later
he came in and just you know I
apologized anyways like I'd been
drinking for a couple weeks I just
hadn't taken it to that level yeah yeah
yeah so so he ball he recalled at all
yeah yeah that's cool sit as fun as soon
as he saw me is like stay away from me
Argus
listen man that was the that was that
horrible to you I was Argus that wasn't
exactly well it is easier to get it
sometimes have poor behavior when you're
like in a character playing care way
that's why the rose' inappropriate thing
you wrote this isn't my home I'm on the
road yeah it's a different person right
yeah that's a great birthday sorry to
hear about Robin but that's a fun 25th
yeah it was a good one man who it was a
super fun and someone I always respected
yeah you know enjoyed watching perform
so yeah able to kind of improv with them
and that's got him enjoy it so much
definitely made me feel like I must be I
got I got this yeah if this guy's love
in itself that's cool Rick Ingram thank
you for being so honest with us yeah
it's not easy to talk about your own
health but but thank you good with it
yeah I'm sorry you had a [ __ ] 30th
that's our I'm happy you're healthy you
are healthy yeah feeling good just turn
35 and doing it's been five great years
you got insulin in that bag I do yes you
do um uh that's why I carry back there
are people like when you're backpacking
it's that or a fanny pack yes not gonna
get me made fun of less yeah what it's
all good it's your healthy can't carry
over the [ __ ] you were right man for 70
is a hell of a blood pressure blood
sugar level yeah yeah I mean in
hindsight when I got those records sent
to me and I looked at him just like what
mother [ __ ] you think i might have
good and bad he thought to do it but he
should have yeah that was yeah um where
can people find out more about your
comedy um what's your twitter handle
it's uh just rick ingram Ric k ingr aham
the other ham yeah okay um Facebook
Twitter got it your Twitter's grey you
call out a lot of [ __ ] which I
appreciate yeah there's some people the
Panda on Twitter I can't do a sadly most
of the successful people on Twitter
pander yeah and you are not one of those
people and I i apprec mean I just I
appreciate it like I try to not pander
either sometimes it happens not just
yeah automatically but I'm trying to
learn how to do all this don't know but
[ __ ] the pay i mean so many successful
twitter handles are just people kissing
celebrities ass and yeah tell me what
they want to hear and that's not
to me that's not what stand-up comedy is
yeah I agree I can't um thank you very
much thanks for having a happy worst
birthday to you Thanks yeah that's Rick
Ingram everybody ban huh that's just a
great story I mean health concerns not
even health concerns he was sick and he
was he was sick his blood sugar level
470 Jesus Christ the more you dig into
the health care in this country we're a
[ __ ] third world country when it
comes to healthcare why is this man he's
literally dying in front of his friends
no wait losing weight throwing up and
he's afraid to go anywhere he's any
[ __ ] money I also love that the cow
Easter nobody at the college there was
like hey man you ever think you're a
diabetic like them one of the most
common sicknesses oh man as just as gray
I appreciate you Rick for coming and
sharing all that honesty with us nothing
like health concerns to [ __ ] you up I
mean it's like even just to something
tiny it's nowhere relatable to him like
a toothache it just ruins your entire
life I remember the last time I had a
tooth problem I'm are calling somebody I
was just like god I can't imagine being
poor like a real poor person how much
more [ __ ] they have to put up with
because I didn't have dental care and i
was going to these shitty dental offices
but i was still able to go to dental
offices and i was able to pay for it
that's not it that's not a portrait but
a poor business have to have nine
different toothaches all at the same
time no money nine jobs a car that
breaks down in my car every time I start
my car it starts it's great but I take
that [ __ ] for granted man I walk out to
my car it's in good shape it's where I
parked it no one's [ __ ] with it i
press Start and it starts every time
it's amazing and when you're sick Rick
was sick for three years I'm so glad
he's better I'm so glad that some doctor
I don't know about dr. Rose was he good
or was he bad
he was good that he checked his blood
sugar level he's back because he didn't
say go to the [ __ ] emergency room
right now now man you got to see Rick
Ingram live I mean I love the story with
Robin Williams telling them how to
perform and tell her giving him advice
on what to do you know Rick does a lot
of crowd work and it in some capacity it
hurts him he doesn't have those credits
the stupid credits that go on a poster
that I have and they go on the poster
but Rick is he's so tough to follow at
the comedy store because he's so funny
and he goes into the audience and then
when he's done he gets off stage and you
follow them and it's just like oh [ __ ]
they don't want to hear just basically
Allah gehen they want to see they want
to see some different and I really love
watching Rick perform and you should do
please check out Rick Ingram I'll have
him his name is Twitter on my Twitter
Michael Kosta please hashtag us hashtag
worst bday pod my website Michael Kosta
calm and The Comedy Store if you're ever
in LA just you got to come see this
place it is fascinating it's dark it's
mysterious it's dirty it's raw it's
honest it's got an edge you know like
you you don't play with it because it'll
cut you but it's it's so fun and it's a
clubhouse male comics female comics male
comics dressed as female comics vice
versa everyone is welcome sometimes you
wish not everyone was welcome sometimes
I'm their drink on the back patio and
I'm like why am I talking to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] get away from me stop
running bits on me comic I've never
heard of before don't even know who you
are but it's just a fun place with
people that don't give a [ __ ] about
labels or being politically correct and
when it comes down to it they are there
for you The Comedy Store and it's just a
special place on Rick Ingram is one of
those guys that's been through so much
there so please check it out it's on
Sunset every single night of the week is
rate I prefer the original room to all
the rooms there's the belly room
upstairs which is a small intimate space
is the main room which is a huge space
seats around 300 if not more feels more
like a you know like a Broadway show
room and then there's the original room
which feels like you're in midtown New
York and its darkest [ __ ] you know and
you can't see everything that's going on
it's mysterious and it's just raw the
comedy is raw there and i love it so
please check out the comedy store it's a
special place and I do think someday
sadly we're going to lose it you know I
know Mitzi sick no one really knows
what's going on with her Pauly Shore his
family owns at Mitzi's his mom and no
one really knows it's a prime real
estate on Sunset Boulevard in LA house
of blues was across the street they're
tearing that plays down building some
[ __ ] luxury hotel or some [ __ ] which
man it would just suck to lose the
comedy store it's a special place so
Rick Ingram ladies and gentlemen
diabetics are you drinking tons of water
are you pissing all the time man it's
interesting I learned a lot about
diabetes with that and I feel like I
know more than most people because my
dad but that was a body shutting down
holy [ __ ] you know I just went to
Walgreens or whatever and I got like a
blood pressure monitor it's 40 bucks and
I can monitor my blood pressure Rick
said it in the podcast if he wouldn't if
you'd if someone would have told him he
would have bought a blood sugar level
reader whatever it's called certainly
not called that but it checks the sugar
levels of your blood you can buy all the
ship pretty cheap [ __ ] you can probably
use it and return it but we do not value
personal health like we should in this
country I'm not getting all political
but it's just [ __ ] that a guy who's
that sick is afraid to go to the [ __ ]
doctor and as the negotiate has to take
the energy to negotiate with an
insurance company or a hospital about
his own health and
cost of it oh man don't even get me
started on dentists those [ __ ] guys
everything's an upsell with a dentist
you guys this is michael kosta this is
the worst birthday podcast thank you for
listening every Thursday we have new
worst birthday stories you can get all
my live dates at Michael Kosta I hope to
see it a live show thanks for listening
this is the worst birthday podcast